And my question is about Google Ads.
So how important is it in the process of this process?
Does it start with Google Ads?
Or is there any other way to do it?
Yeah, so it's up to you guys.
I personally prefer using Google Ads
because I like to pre-sell my sites.
I like to go and get that deal upfront.
However, there's the other way to do it,
which is the traditional way.
I'll call it the traditional way, which is where you go,
you pick a city, you pick a niche, you rank the website,
then you go and sell it.
So if you're somebody, let's say you
don't have a lot of capital and you're
nervous to spend money on ads, I still
would argue it's better to go get the deal upfront.
But maybe you're not confident in your ability
to sell it, whatever, and that's what you want to do.
That is fine.
If you want, you could start at the second half
of the training, build a website, rank it,
and then go and start using the first half of the training
to sell the deal.
So you can do it either way.
I just prefer going into it and getting paid
while the website's ranking.
OK, so when you're running Google Ads,
do you do test out three, four sites or properties,
or you just run with one and then see if it is validated,
or you just stop it, or you continue to sell it off?
So how do you start with three, four properties
at the same time?
When you first start, I would recommend starting with one.
But once you get going and you've gotten that first deal,
you can start adding two.
And then once you figure that out,
you can start adding three.
And then what I do is once one website, one ad
starts to really work.
I start to get leads.
Then I pause the other two and I focus on the one and so forth.
So when you first start, you probably
want to start with one.
Got it?
Awesome, Moin.
Let's go get a deal, brother.
One thing I want to remind you of,
make sure that you're focusing on asking people for money.
Because no matter what you do, no matter how much content you
do, no matter how many backlinks you do,
no matter how many websites you look at,
unless you're asking people for money,
you're not going to make money.
Make sense?
Yeah.
Awesome, Moin, thanks for helping out, brother.
We'll talk soon.
And let's go get a deal, dude.